when many designers talk about stripes
they tend to mention how much they stand
out the stripe is possibly the most
noticeable pattern the immediate and
repetitive change from one color to
another calls attention to itself which
explains why caution signs are almost
exclusively striped along with other
things you need to see like lighthouses
signaling flags and the old fashioned
barbershop pole and so it's no
coincidence that the most famous cartoon
you're always trying to look for has a
striped shirt he doesn't blend in the
designer of the IBM logo said it right
stripes attract attention the visual
power of the pattern possibly comes from
the inability to distinguish a stripes
foreground from its background there's
something visually confusing about the
layers of a stripe notice how every
optical illusion or hypnosis video uses
stripes
there's even an evolutionary theory that
zebras wear stripes to confuse predators
of their number and distance it works so
well humans copied the technique for
world war ii battleships and remember
that none of these traits apply as
strongly to other patterns chequered
feels more orderly plaid is less jarring
and spots have a clear foreground and
background stripes are the most extreme
stripes are different and these unique
properties of stripes have made them
powerful symbols that have eventually
evolves into signs of oppression
deviance freedom and daring style no
matter where stripes are they are never
subtle Michael for this video is to talk
about the theories of design and
symbolism of the stripe in art history
and design and apply those ideas to the
stripes and movies the significance of
stripes in cinema is actually
surprisingly under researched but the
meaning of stripes in art and design
should apply to movies as well if not
more so Michael pastor Roe and author of
a book on the history of stripes did
have one movie in mind when discussing
the power of stripes historically
spellbound by Alfred Hitchcock stars a
man with a phobia of lines against a
white background a man with an actual
fear of stripes
I doubt a movie could pull that off with
any other pattern and it just goes to
show how the contrast of stripes has
massive appeal to the eye of the
filmmaker if stripes can literally be
somebody's phobia in a movie they must
mean something but I'm getting ahead of
myself
historically the natural properties of
stripes gave them symbolic meaning in
Western Europe and their power at that
time can't be underestimated
when a stripe were and Catholic
religious group came to Europe from the
Crusader States in the 12th century they
were ridiculed for how they were dressed
to the
at Pope Alexander the fourth banned all
clergy men from wearing stripes in the
Middle Ages when the type of clothing
always indicated your social status
stripes pointed out the deviance of
society anybody who wasn't an honest
citizen in art strike people are more
often than not the jesters prostitutes
executioner's or traders in a 12th
century painting God gives Adam and Eve
a striped garment before they are
expelled from paradise in this case the
stripes indicate they have committed
acts of shame and sin similarly the
striped bedding in this 14th century
French painting shows the immorality of
what they're doing in an era where what
you wore was a clear indication of your
social status the flashiness of the
stripe meant you were a social deviant
and its meaning was taken very seriously
it was often even associated with
monsters and the devil
this traditional perception of stripes
made its way into the movies many
deviant women in film have worn stripes
maybe the most convincing example is how
the Wicked Witch of the East is
distinguished only by her boldly striped
black and white stockings that same year
Dallas in stagecoach has a similar
striped moment and she's a prostitute in
the movie
[Music]
possibly originating in the penal
colonies of America prisoners also wore
stripes as a uniform again it's a
classic sign of the deviant and movies
are no different and while the stripe as
a badge of shame continued later
centuries introduced different
interpretations of the pattern starting
in the 16th century stripes shifted from
being strictly diabolic into tamer
eventually positive meanings it became a
uniform for servants and found its way
on textiles integrating its way into the
home most importantly however is the
American Revolution introducing the
striped flag as a symbol of rebellion
they took a pattern used for the
prisoners of the American South and made
it their battle cry showing how they
felt like prisoners under British rule
the French followed suit and from then
on those in favor of the movement of
freedom could wear stripes to show their
support
really the stripes meaning hadn't
explicitly changed it's still a sign of
an outsider or a deviant as the
revolutionaries clearly were but it's no
longer exclusively negative movies show
these multiple interpretations of the
stripe in some cases the pattern is a
sign of the delinquent in others they
are worn on purpose to signal somebody
unique the dual meaning of stripes even
shows itself in nature a study of
stripes in 2015 mentioned how many
animals use them as a warning to signal
an unpleasant consequence of an attack
while others use stripes to attract
attention from a potential mate so
stripes can be equally good or bad
American cinema in the 1950s showed the
rebellious meaning of the stripe coming
to the big screen with many high-profile
actors wearing the Breton stripe in
movies directed at teens and young
adults all worn by characters who don't
follow the status quo this movement also
spread to artists philosophers and the
Ramones
so what stripes also being worn as a
point of pride we see people using
stripes to stand out on purpose a
classic example is the gangster
gangsters actually wore pinstripes in
real life and that style made its way
into the movies gangsters outfits
commonly have stripes to look flashy as
they flaunt their wealth and status to
the point that some of them look
tasteless for the most crooked
over-the-top male characters notice how
crazy the stripes become the kind of
stripe also matters long thick stripes
seem to go to the flashy characters but
thin sleek stripes look more fashionable
you can make the argument that
filmmakers use bold stripes on
businessmen to make them seem more
crooked but stripes can also look very
chic old structure calls for solid color
discreetly pattern suits inside the more
pronounced the striped the crazier
filmmaking has certainly taken advantage
of the disorienting nature of the strife
it's no coincidence that a striped cat
is an illusionist and the introduction
to cycle works because the imbalance of
the stripes looks off like the slicing
of a knife there's also a complicated
relationship between stripes children
and hygiene michelle pastor rose study
of stripes mentions how underwear and
undergarments were completely white
because the people of the Middle Ages
saw dyes and coloring as a form of
contamination
while lightness was pure and healthy as
a result no color ever directly touched
the body in the 20th century however the
strike became a way to add style to
pajamas towels and underwear while
keeping some whiteness in the clothing
so in the current day Prince George is
always wearing stripes because it has
become a symbol of hygiene but there's
also a little bit of the original
meaning of stripes and that children are
playfully deviant not quite fitting in
with society completely and so some
filmmakers use stripes to evoke a
childishness to characters which is in
its own way a form of deviance ever
since the jesters and jugglers in the
medieval ages mankind has had an
understanding that stripes can also look
childish silly and funny now I'm not
saying that all the stripes done in
movies were done with knowledge of the
stripes history it's actually the
opposite nobody had even considered the
meaning or history of stripes until the
last decade or so what I'm trying to say
is the design of the stripe naturally
causes it to stand out and so it makes
sense that in movies where a wardrobe is
meticulously chosen filmmakers
subconsciously or consciously used that
extreme change from one color to the
next to tell us something about the
character maybe they're downright evil
or they're a rebellious teen either way
the stripes help show they are a deviant
from the status quo in some way and
movies understand this dual meaning
think about the title of the boy in the
Striped Pyjamas in one sense striped
pajamas are a sign of fashion comfort
and the playful child but the audience
knows the real reason his clothes were
striped the movie's title plays on our
culture's multiple interpretations of
the stripe Juno is perhaps the most
complicated and effective the use of
stripes I've seen in the movies it's the
pattern Juno wears most often and it
became her symbol in the trailers and
poster art it fits her character
perfectly she's playful childish and
stands out with her sharp over-the-top
dialogue but she's also a deviant as a
pregnant teenager she self identifies as
rebellious and has unconventional taste
in music
style she commands attention both good
and bad and the stripes are the perfect
companion to her character but no matter
what they're used for stripes always
stand out they made Joseph Scott stand
out in the Bible and they complement
Juno's uncontained wit we're just
starting to see more research into the
symbolism of the stripe and I invite you
to look into it yourself I recently
noticed the evil gremlin is named stripe
and it totally fits with the original
association of stripes with monsters and
how he's a deviant as the gremlin that's
the most evil I'm sure there are tons of
other examples of stripes and movies out
there I haven't come across check out
now you see it blog slash stripes to see
all the examples of stripes I have
compiled so far if you think of any
stripes and movies or come across any in
the future there's another link where
you can submit the name of the film who
wears the stripes and what the possible
meaning might be in the description I'll
continue adding screenshots to make the
first compiled collection of stripes in
film available on the internet graphic
designers have understood the power of
stripes for a long time even before
there was any research on them the IBM
logo is a famous example but you can
also look at adidas Apple and AT&T to
see how companies use stripes to convey
speed and going against the status quo
professional logo designers are some of
the few people who do understand the
meaning of the stripe one of the premier
logo designers in the business currently
is Aaron droplet a designer for Nike
Ford and even the Obama administration
if you want to learn the secrets of
great logo design you can sign up for
his class on Skillshare Skillshare has
over 20,000 classes on topics ranging
from photography to business the first
500 people to click on the link in the
description below can get two months of
completely free access to Skillshare
that's the logo design class plus
thousands of others across
cinematography video editing photography
marketing and business thanks for
watching and a big THANK YOU to
Skillshare for sponsoring this video